I think I wanted to talk to you about
the big thing this week and that I've
been hearing about a lot lately
is free speech and political correctness
so I don't know if you saw this Jerry
Seinfeld no just don't belittle campuses
don't go to college campuses there too
PC everything's racist or homophobic or
agreed with that so Bill Maher has been
talking about even Larry the Cable Guy
so when you have Bill Maher Seinfeld
Chris Rock Larry the Cable Guy although
our campus is that way because I I have
a sense that they are that that
unfortunately we're teaching young
people that anything that you say that
is sort of out of the the mainstream
think is automatically evil it's
automatically racing totally totally
that shouldn't be I'm funny I love funny
people Lenny Bruce was a great friend of
mine George Carlin yeah these guys ran
against the grain and healthy comedy a
lot of it hits home but it's true it's
come on yeah and college campuses is
where irreverence should take place yeah
why would a college campus be a place
where you have to be politically correct
I would think the college campus would
be the opposite well it's supposed to be
the opposite right but somehow they they
go there and they somehow learn that
anyone who says so if you say anything
that might sound slightly against women
that automatically you hate all women or
if you believe in an economic policy
that maybe isn't isn't seen as
redistributing the way that they want
then you're then you're racist there's
just this strange Omar would not be
popular on campuses well that's the
irony
you know Berkeley remember Berkeley
didn't want him to the kids at Berkeley
didn't want him to speak and then and
then he did but there was a petition
portion of a port yeah Portia and then
of course they did allow him to speak
and shines over Seinfeld wouldn't be
allowed to speak at a college yeah I
can't I don't buy that I mean he says it
but Ramon well the idea of Seinfeld who
of course is what all knowledge would
most politically correct comedian of all
time do you know is how many times have
you interviewed him I'm sure yeah and do
you know any of his political beliefs
and I was in a movie with him the
terrific
the the Beeman yeah Harry B King was a B
fact more kids you know me from that
than anything else I don't know what its
part but that's fine yeah
doesn't that show you how silly the
atmosphere is if a guy that you don't
know their political believes a why
won't son fell workers campus if that's
what they want well he said that he
based it around this silly gauge oak
that he made about a French King swiping
an iPhone with a limp wrist and he said
wow people are saying that that's that's
homophobic and you know of course that's
not homophobic it's just a silly joke it
would take a you would need a history I
think that's what people need to learn
you would need a history of saying
something against a certain group of
people they're actually be bigoted or
racist Rickles is hysterical and he's
but but you take no prisoners yeah great
comedian takes no prisoners yeah you
think we're a guy like Rickles could
make it today he's funny and give it to
me if you're funny you're funny
Mel Brooks is the funniest man I've
known funniest man I've ever seen and
know Brooks has it down the hell Brooks
has the philosophy of humor he has put
the best ready I'll give you the Mel
Brooks philosophy it applies to all
cases at all times if you fall down a
manhole it's funny
if I cut my finger it's tragic